ON REBOUND.
AND THEN SAVEROLINA HURRICANES
ZERO IN THIS FIRST PERIOD.
MIKE.TRYING TO
CLEAR.
AND RIGHT IN FRONT, DAVID
PASTRNAK.
>> Shane: THE WORK AWAY.
VINCENT TROCHECK ACROSS THE
BLUE LINE.
THIS WILL STOP THE PLAY WITH
18E  THIRD POWER PLAY.
AND HE WILL GIVE THIS AWAY.
>> Shane: I LIKE THE DIFFERENT
LOOKS THEY ARE GOING WITH  YOU
NOT JUST WITH THE HOCKEY
STICKS, WITH YOUR BODY.
STAY PHYSICAL WITHTH
VINCENT TROCHECK.
13:59 LEFT IN THE SECOND
PERIOD.
KEPT IN.EKING YET ELITE
SHOTS.
THE FIRST OY.
AND JORDAN STAAL.
AND  THE ERIC AND
ALRERE
POPPED IN.
TAKING THE HIT.
AND ANOTHER POWER PLAY GOAL FOR
TO TAKE AWAY THAT PASS
4-0.  THIS ONE IS RUNNING AWAY.
AND THE . AND HE
CHARGES IN.
HE WILL SCORE.
A COUNTER.
COACH ROD BRIND'AMOUR IS
LOOKING THIS FOR AN OFFSMATT GR
DANCE AROUND JESPERI .  VINCENT
SHORTHTH
EMPTY NET.